HAPPENING.
>> David: A CHRISTMAS
PRESENT.
JOINING US WITH REACTION RNC
CHAIR RONNA MCDANIEL.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
WE HAVE TALKED THROUGH THIS
ENTIRE PROCESS ON RADIO AND
IN PERSON ABOUT THIS AND A
MAJOR ACHIEVEMENT THE
PRESIDENT GETS A MAJOR
LEGISLATIVE WIN.
AND THE RNC I SAID TO THEM
YOU GUYS HAVE TO TAKE IT TO
THE STREETS.
WHERE DO YOU BEGIN?
>> IT IS HISTORIC DAY.
TAPS GREAT CHRISTMAS
PRESENT.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP LED THE
WAY.
YOU KNOW, I THINK ABOUT A
YEAR AGO WHEN HE WAS COMING
TO MY STATE OF MICHIGAN AND
TRAVELING THIS COUNTRY, AND
RECOGNIZING THAT WAGES WERE
STAGNANT, THAT PEOPLE WERE
SUFFERING.
AND NOW TODAY, HE HAS SAID
WE ARE FIGHTING FOR YOU.
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE THE
MIDDLE CLASS A HUGE TAX CUT.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE YOUR
PAYCHECK BIGGER.
WE ARE GOING TO INCREASE
JOBS.
WE'RE GOING TO GROW OUR
ECONOMY.
WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SO, AT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
HAMMERING HOME THE GREAT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THIS THE
'AND SENATOR MCCONNELL AND
SPEAKER RYAN.
AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO
REMIND THEM THAT THE
DEMOCRATS WERE NOWHERE TO BE
FOUND.
IN FACT, JOE MANCHIN WENT
HOME AND HE SAW A BIG BANNER
THAT SAID WE'LL REMEMBER IN
NOVEMBER.
WELL, WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THEY REMEMBER IN
NOVEMBER THAT NO DEMOCRAT
SUPPORTED MIDDLE CLASS TAX
CUTS IN HELPING THE AMERICAN
THE MAJOR DRIVER OF THE
ECONOMY AND THAT IS THE
CORPORATE SIDE OF THIS.
AND I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE MEGA CORPORATIONS.
S CORPS.
INDIVIDUAL TRUCKERS CALL
EVERY DAY AND ASK WHAT DOES
THIS MEAN TO ME?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO THEM
THE PEOPLE IN THAT 50 TO
$75,000 INCOME LEVEL?
BUT THEY HAVE A PASS
WHAT DOES IT MEAN TO THEM?
>> WELL, IT MEANS THEY ARE
GOING TO TAKE MORE MONEY
HOME.
IT'S TWO-FOLD.
TWO-FOLD IN THAT WE HAVE CUT
SO MANY REGULATIONS.
THE PRESIDENT FOCUSED ON
THAT AT THE FIRST THREE
MONTHS OF HIS ADMINISTRATION
CUTTING REGULATIONS.
THE SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
BECAUSE THEY WERE SO
CONSTRICTED BY THESE
CUMBERSOME REGULATIONS THAT
WERE PREVENTING THEM FROM
GROWING AND BEING ABLE TO
EXPAND THEIR BUSINESSES.
SO THAT.
AND THEN COUNTY TAX CUTS
TAKE MORE MONEY HOME.
TRUCK DRIVERS, PEOPLE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE GOING TO
TRUMP TARGETED WITH THIS
HUGE TAX REFORM BILL.
>> David: ALL RIGHT.
ED HENRY BROUGHT IT UP A
LITTLE WHILE AGO, RONNA.
HAS A GOOD POINT.
CAN THE REPUBLICANS WRITE A
30-SECOND AD THAT LAYS OUT
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHAT
SECONDS?
>> REPUBLICANS ARE PUTTING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST.
AND WE ARE INCREASING THEIR
PAYCHECKS.
WE ARE GOING TO FOCUS ON
CREATING MORE JOBS.
WE ARE GOING TO INCREASE
AMERICANS.
AND WE HAVE DELIVERED AT
EVERY TURN THIS YEAR.
WE ARE ARE GOING TO KEEP
DOING IT GIVE US THE
MAJORITY IN 2018.
>> David: NOW LET'S TALK
ABOUT SOME OTHER THINGS.
I WOULD LIKE TO COVER THE
THINGS NOT ALWAYS THERE.
TAX CUTS.
WHAT ABOUT OTHER THINGS?
REGULATORY REFORM.
WE HAVE IMMIGRATION ON THE
TABLE TO DEAL WITH DACA.
WE HAVE SO MANY ISSUES.
PARTY.
IS THE PARTY GOING TO COME
PRESIDENT BORDER TO LOOK AT
THESE WALLS.
>> SO MUCH HAS BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED IN THIS YEAR AS
WE LOOK AT THE YEAR IN
REVIEW.
LOOK AT THE JUDICIAL
APPOINTMENTS.
LOOK AT NEIL GORSUCH, LOOK
AT VETERANS ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT.
LOOK AT INCREASED MILITARY
SPENDING AND DEREGULATION
AND TAX CUTS.
WE ARE JUST GOING TO KEEP
DOING THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
SIGNALED HE WANTS TO TACKLE
FRACTURE NEXT YEAR.
ACCOMPLISHMENT COLUMN FOR
REPUBLICANS.
HAVE DEMOCRATS DONE THIS
YEAR?
WHAT HAVE THEY ACCOMPLISHED?
FIGHTING THIS PRESIDENT AT
EVERY TURN EVEN IF IT'S IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THEIR
CONSTITUENTS IS NOT A
MESSAGE THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO RUN ON IN
2018.
PARTY.
WE CAN GOVERNOR AS A PARTY.
WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
FIGHTING FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
OUR HAND IS OUT TO
DEMOCRATS.
WE WANT THEM TO COME ACROSS
THE AISLE AND WORK WITH US.
IF THEY ARE NOT GOING TO, WE
ARE GOING TO GET IT DONE.
>> ARE THEY REALLY GOING
COME ACROSS THE AISLE AS WE
WRAP THIS UP.
WE HEARD CHUCK SCHUMER SAY
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
ROUX THE DAY WHEN THEY DO
THIS.
NANCY PELOSI, THIS IS THE
WORST THING.
THIS IS ARMAGEDDON.
I'M PARAPHRASING.
YOU KNOW THE WORDS THAT ARE
BEING USED.
AND THEY ARE NOT READING THE
BILLS.
NOTHING NEW FOR DEMOCRATS.
OHIO THINK ARE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT 2018.
JOE MANCHIN, HEIDI HEITCAMP.
JOE DONNELLY, JOHN TESTER,
STATES WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP
WON, THEY WANT THE PHOTO OP.
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THEY WANT TO TO SHOW THEY
ARE BIPARTISAN.
SO FAR THEY ARE TOTALLY
BEHOLDEN TO THEIR LEADERSHIP
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK
SCHUMER.
WHEN THEY GO TO THE BALLOT
BOX THEY WILL ASK WHAT DID
MY SENATOR DO.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITIES TO
PICK UP SEATS THEY F. THEY
CAN'T COME ACROSS THE AISLE
AND WORK ON OTHER THINGS
ESPECIALLY MIDDLE CLASS TAX
CUTS AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> David: THANKS, RONNA.
BY THE WAY GREAT TO SEE YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY.
YOU WORKED VERY HARD IN THE
FIRST PART OF THIS TERM.